[Music]
welcome back to the Ingram angle I'm
Raymond Arroyo sitting in for Laura
president Trump is gearing up for a
fight with Congress over funding for a
new border wall with a migrant caravan
knocking at our southern border the
President believes we need the wall now
and it couldn't be more apparent or
urgent could happen over border security
the wall is just a part of border secure
very important I probably the most
important part but could there be a
shutdown there certainly could and it
will be about border security in which
the wall is apart is a shutdown looming
here now to react is David Burstein CEO
and founder of run for America and a
progressive commentator and Audria
Dekker
she's a conservative commentator let me
start with you Audrey does the president
have enough support in the GOP to get
his border wall funding he couldn't get
it last time right well regardless of if
he has the support or not his job is to
enforce the laws that are on the books
and the fact is is we have borders in
our nation people can't just decide
they're gonna cross over without
permission and we need a system in
America that is fair to the people
waiting in line and so also the people
that want to come over so absolutely he
needs to do whatever he needs to to
secure the border but the Republicans
haven't joined him there's there's this
unity in the caucus I want to play
something for you David this is
congressman Pete King talking about this
government shutdown and who it might
hurt watch I strongly support funding
the border wall but I don't believe we
just shut the government down given our
gauge to keep the government going and
also politically this would play into
the hands of the Democrats we all get
blamed for shutting down the government
the wall won't be built the wall won't
be funded and we'll get the blame for it
won't this hurt Republicans I think
however the Republicans I would be
worried about that because the reality
is people just voted for changing that
they really voted for us people voted
for action shutting down the government
is not what people are looking for and
you and being president there's a
responsibility to get more than one
thing done at a time and you know he may
not get this priority on this guy'll it
didn't hurt when Newt Gingrich did it
years ago I was covering the rebel then
and they turned out pretty well where is
Paul Ryan
why not in his final act a stranger and
with this caucus many of these people
are leaving why not support the
president in this promise he made to the
American people that got many of them
elected the last time well that's the
thing is that the Republicans should be
fighting for this and they're not and I
think part of the reason why Trump has
brought this up is that he's a great
negotiator and we know that he sometimes
has to push the Republican party to take
action on important issues and this is
an issue that President Trump ran on and
got elected on so the American people do
want to see this happen it's almost
Christmas time let me run through the
GOP lame-duck wishlist these are the
things they hope to accomplish they
don't have a lot to get done they want
to get a 10% tax cut they want building
the border wall stopping birthright
citizenship cutting off US and Central
American nations aid and protecting
pre-existing conditions will any of that
get accomplished David well I think
maybe one or two of those things will
get accomplished it seems that people
get suddenly find their political energy
in the last days when they when they
suddenly have for their constituents
have told them they no longer 15 days
legislative days left for the Senate
twelve in the house that's not that's
not an attorney I have to say it's
amazing that there seem to be three
months where nobody could find anything
to do except campaign and now in the
last 15 days of the year suddenly
there's a list of priorities will get it
all done okay the Democrats also have a
lot to get to Andreea here's what
they're planning they are they have put
forward their own little wish list it
includes looking at president Trump's
tax returns his family business
Trump's dealing with Russia the stormy
Daniels payment and the James Comey
firing and there are more things coming
by Ivanka's phone calls like this could
go on for another ten minutes your
thoughts on what this will mean are we
basically talking about gridlock yeah
well and I don't think this is
beneficial for the Democratic Party
either let's talk about the issues that
Americans care about let's have a real
discussion around the issues and the
principles and let's see where we fall
on them let's see let's have deals
negotiated in Congress on behalf of the
American people stop going after Trump
put out your solutions in your policy
okay I'm going to turn to 2020 the
Democratic contenders are beginning to
emerge as you know president former vice
president
Joe Biden it's at the top of that list
33% of Democrats like him according to
that last CNN poll and there you see the
huge field it looks like the Brady Bunch
on viagra there just exploded your cause
who's going to take the lead here David
whose remains this is gonna be a very
very tough race and I had to look at
anyone on that sheet I saw a picture of
the rock I think of the rock runs he's
probably got his best shot but but I do
think really this is a crowded field and
Democrats would actually do well to
consolidate early and not let this plate
be a repeat of 2020 of 2016 where they
end up in a situation with one person
who's able to be the loudest like
president Trump was in his where I heard
him who's able to kind of dominate
everybody else than 46 percent of voters
think President Trump will win again 47%
don't in that last CNN poll those are
pretty good numbers who would you like
to see the Dems run against Trump well
you know it's interesting I think we
should keep an eye on senator Cory
Booker and Senator Harris those are two
interesting people or Rorick out of
Texas raised a lot of money interesting
to keep an eye on him but this election
is gonna come down to values I think
it's gonna be about values president
Trump proves that people voted for Trump
not for his personality but for the
values and so I think both sides are
pretty divided right now I think it's
gonna become about competency and safety
given what we're doing and how this
economy ends up before we go I have to
get your reactions to this liberal
filmmaker Michael Moore who just this
summer called on people to put their
bodies on the line to stop the president
well he's now calling for the shunning
of Trump supporters watch this
this one's hard you can't build a bridge
to a racist or a misogynist
you know they have they have to be
shunned and treated like we treated
smokers 20 years ago 10 years ago racist
and misogynist shunned so all Trump
supporters are basically racist and
misogynist they should be shunned Audria
your reaction yeah name-calling doesn't
help anything we need to be able to have
a conversation in America where both
sides come together and maybe disagree
with each other but do it respectfully
and with civility and we don't need more
of that in America that kind of rhetoric
is divisive and it's dangerous David
isn't this kind of silly it reminded me
of the attacks this week on a Charlie
Brown Christmas where people are now
saying critics are saying your race
is Charlie Brown because there's
Franklin the black friend who's at the
other side of the Thanksgiving table I
mean this is really isn't it's too far
the use of race to demonize people a
whole swath of America yes I think we've
gone too far in it at this time of year
when everybody's coming together and
solving the holidays I hope people in
Washington could find it in their hearts
to say let's work the you look at that
and hear everybody David in the break
we're going to see